-One of our next guests tonight
is a 10-time NBA All Star
and three-time
Olympic gold medalist.
The other is a very funny and
talented comedian and writer.
Their Wave Sports and
Entertainment original series,
"7PM in Brooklyn," is available
Thursdays on YouTube
and wherever you get
your podcasts.
Please welcome Carmelo Anthony
and the Kid Mero, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome, gentlemen.
I'm so happy you're here.
-Now, Mero,
you've been here before.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And I feel like this
is maybe beyond
a dream come true
that you're hosting
a sort of sports
and culture show
with Carmelo here.
-I don't believe I'm still here.
I wanted you to come around
the desk and pinch me...
-Yeah.
-...so that I can feel that
this is a real situation.
-Ah.
-Were you worried
about your safety
when you realized
what a big fan Kid Mero was?
-I was out of New York
at that time.
-Yeah.
-So I was -- I was distanced.
-But these are
some of the things --
This is a man
you are hosting a show with.
These are things back in 2017
he tweeted, "Melo must --"
"Melo, most clutch player
in the
National Basketball Association,
debate your mom's
new boyfriend, not me."
[ Laughter ]
-Am I wrong? If I am, debate
your mom's new boyfriend.
-And then, this was even older.
In 2010,
"If Carmelo Anthony signs
with the Nets,
I ain't even watching
basketball no more.
[bleep] that #Knicks."
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
You might be the first --
You might be the first person
who needs a restraining order
against your own podcast
co-host.
-At least I got --
He's on my side now, so we good.
-Yeah. That's true.
He is on your side.
-We teammates.
-Now you are -- famously,
you represent the Bronx.
-Oh, all day.
-But, Melo,
you're from Brooklyn.
And then the name of the show
is "7PM in Brooklyn."
How quickly
did you give it up, Mero?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, you know.
I would say 2 1/2 Zooms.
-Okay.
-You know what I'm saying?
-You fought --
You fought for 2 1/2 Zooms.
That's noble.
-I was like, "7PM?
Yeah, it's good, brother.
Yeah, yeah."
My voice went up
a couple octaves.
Know what I'm saying?
[ High-pitched ]
"I like it, I like it."
[ Laughter ]
-One of the things you guys
have been talking about is,
and I feel like a lot of people
would say has been a success,
the in-season NBA tournament.
-Facts.
-Seemed like it got
a lot of people's attention
during a time of the season
maybe usually doesn't.
Do you feel
like it worked out well?
-For sure.
It's a -- It's a success.
Take my hat off
to Adam Silver and NBA.
The in-season tournament
is crazy.
-Are you bummed that
you never got to play in one?
-I don't think we was thinking
that far ahead back then.
We were just in it now
back then,
so we wasn't really worried
about in-season tournament.
But I wish I did play
in in-season tournament.
-Yeah. It did seem like --
And you're okay
with the way the floors looked?
-I mean, 80% of them.
-Yeah.
-It was a small percentage
that were like, you know...
-You know, some of them
was just like,
"A'ight, we're gonna redo this."
-Yeah.
Do you guys, um --
Do you ever play "NBA 2K"?
-I do.
-And when you play,
do you play as Melo.
-I do.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But I get my --
my old Denver Nuggets build
on a New York Knicks build.
-Yeah.
-I go out there and play.
-He prefers the Knicks still.
-Like, is there a --
Is there a build of your career
that you enjoy playing
with the most?
Does it make you long
for days past?
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
I still be trying to prove to
people that I can get it done.
So I play with the Knicks,
and I just like -- this is --
I went on the game.
-Yeah. All right. Good.
Do you ever play?
-I do play.
-Have you ever played together?
Have you ever
played against Melo?
-He would --
He would wash me
physically in basketball
and digitally in basketball.
So I'm not stepping
into that arena.
-That's awful.
I mean, I think we all knew
he could beat you physically,
but you can't even compete
on "NBA 2K"?
-Listen, I'm getting fried
by my 8-year-old son.
-Okay, yeah.
-All right?
I'm not not there yet.
-Is your is your 8-year-old son
impressed that
you're hanging out
with Carmelo now?
-Oh, my 10-year-old son is
crazy, jumping into every Zoom.
"Yo, is that Melo?
Yo, what's up, man?!"
I'm like, "He's on
the computer, bro.
He can't sign your jersey
through the computer."
-Right.
-That was the half Zoom
that he was talking about.
-That was the half Zoom.
You -- You appeared --
You've got a son, Kiyan,
who is --
He hasn't decided, right?
He's still in high school.
-He's undecided, yes.
-But he is a --
He's a very coveted recruit.
Here he visited Syracuse,
where you played.
-Yes.
-That would be very exciting.
I would imagine you want
to make sure he makes
his own choice, though, right?
-He will make his own choice.
-Okay.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-He will make his own choice.
[ Laughter ]
-He's trying
to convince himself!
-You starting to believe it?
You're starting to believe it.
[ Laughter ]
-That's -- He's "Just keep
saying it, keep saying it."
-Um, you, uh --
You did --
I think if you want him
to make his own choice,
what I think you should
try to do
is stay out of his TikToks?
He was doing a TikTok dance.
This went a little viral.
You did --
Did you just sort of realize
that TikTok --
You sort of wandered in, and
then you made the most of it.
-I was being Sunday,
couch potato, watching sports,
wanted something
from the kitchen,
head down,
walking to the kitchen,
and I see the camera.
I see them dancing.
-Yeah.
-I was expecting them
to get rid of the video and say,
"Yo, you messed my video up.
We gonna redo it," but...
-They realized they had a hit.
They knew a hit
when they had one.
-They got the clicks.
[ Laughter ]
-I will say, as a dad,
I'm very impressed
at how you leaned into this.
Let's take a look.
-♪ Up and down, up and down,
up and down, up and down ♪
♪ Up and down, up, down, up ♪
♪ Let me hit it, let me hit it,
let me hit it, let me hit it ♪
♪ Let me hit it, let me hit it ♪
♪ Let me hit it, let me hit it,
let me hit it, let me hit it ♪
♪ Let me hit it, let me hit ♪
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Just one.
[ Laughs ]
-You got a very -- a very nice
review from your friend
and colleague LeBron James,
who used all the emojis.
[ Laughter ]
I will say "The foot, though,"
is a nice observation.
The foot was a real --
For someone
who didn't know they were
about to be in a TikTok video,
it looked like
you've been practicing.
But I got great footwork.
-Yeah, that's true.
Historically great footwork.
-Historically great footwork.
-Have you ever wandered
into any of your kids TikToks?
Are they too young?
-They do delete them
when I wander into them
because I'm like,
"Yo, why you drinking
an entire gallon of milk?"
-Yeah.
-You know what I'm saying?
Like, what is that?
What is that?
The milk challenge?
-Cinnamon challenge?
-At least the dance challenges
aren't using up --
-That's cool!
-Using up goods that you've paid
your money for, right?
-Ki's doing cool stuff.
My kids are eating,
like, rock salt.
Like, why?
Why are you doing that?
-What's the rock
salt challenge?
-They invented it, I guess.
Know what I'm saying?
Cut it out!
-It's not taken off,
I don't think.
-No, no.
-I don't think so.
-Three views.
-How does it --
[ Laughter ]
-One is me, one is mom,
and one is -- I don't know.
-The school counselor
where you're like,
"This is your fault!"
-"See?!"
-What do you --
When you guys sit down,
does it come pretty easily
when you start talking
and doing your podcast?
Do you put a lot of prep into it
or you just feel
like your chemistry
and you just go hit
the ground running?
-I think the chemistry.
I think the chemistry.
A lot of times, it's --
we're speaking on topics that
people want to hear about.
-Yeah.
-And having him by my side,
it gives you another angle,
another perspective on
how to look at sports from a fan
as opposed to somebody who --
[ Laughter ]
What not to look at from a fan
as opposed to
how I look at the game.
-Now, obviously,
I would imagine
over the course of your career,
there are good fans
and bad fans, right?
-Of course, of course.
-Are there ever times
where Kid Mero's saying
something, and you're like,
"This is why you're --
This is the problem with fans"?
[ Laughter ]
"Like, you think --
You think because
you watch basketball,
you know, basketball."
Do you ever have to sort of
put him in his place
and be like,
"You don't understand."
-Not yet. Not yet.
-Not yet. Okay.
-We haven't
watched enough basketball
for me to put him in his place.
-I'm sure it'll happen.
-Yeah.
-Know what I'm saying?
-Well, I --
I'm very confident
that you're gonna say
whatever's on your mind,
no matter what.
-Oh, he does anyway.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Come on. You know me.
-Um, you, uh --
I forgot about --
You were in a very special
"SNL" sketch.
You were in the musical
episode of "Laser Cats."
-We not about to show that.
-Well...
[ Laughter ]
-Emmy-worthy.
Emmy stuff.
-It was Emmy-worthy.
Did you --
Did you have any memory of it?
Before I said it, do you
remember doing "Laser Cats"?
-I -- I do.
-Yeah.
-I was trying to, you know,
get rid of that, but...
-Yeah.
The Internet's forever.
-Internet wins.
The Internet wins again.
-The Internet wins again.
I had forgotten that it was the
musical episode of "Laser Cats."
So not only did you appear in
"Laser Cats," you had to sing.
And let me just say,
I had no idea
what a beautiful voice you have.
-Me either.
-Yeah.
It was amazing.
[ Laughter ]
So you were finding out
in real time with America?
-Absolutely.
-All right, let's take a look.
This is very brief.
It's a very brief cameo.
Don't blink or you miss it.
Here's Carmelo in "Laser Cats."
-Please blink.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ We found it ♪
♪ We're gonna sneak right in ♪
-Carmelo Anthony?!
-♪ I should arrest you guys ♪
♪ But you seem pretty cool ♪
Go, Knicks.
♪♪
-Real good.
-You see?
-That's one of -- That's one
of them appearances...
-Yeah.
-...that the team make you do.
Like, "Hey,
we got 12 appearances.
You have to go do one,"
and that's one of them.
-Oh, the team made you do it.
They were like,
"Yeah, Carmelo,
put on your Knicks stuff
and go over to 'SNL.'"
-Welcome to New York.
-Yeah, welcome to New York.
Well, man, it's just so great
to have both of you guys
in New York City.
It's so great
that you're working together
and doing this
really fun podcast.
And thanks so much
for making time for us.
-Thank you.
-Great to see you again.
Great to see you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Carmelo Anthony, The Kid Mero,
everybody!
"7PM in Brooklyn" is available
Thursdays on YouTube
and wherever
you get your podcasts.
We'll be right back
with Leo Reich.